the men shapiro show has received over
100 000 reviews
it makes me happy to say the vast
majority of them are incredibly positive
but
there are always a few haters haters
going to hate in the words of a great
artist so
today i am taking a look at the mean
reviews folks have left as well as a
couple of nice ones for
good measure before we do that this
video is sponsored by raycon
trucker bob says smart conservative talk
ben has got to be one of the smartest
fast-talking conservatives i've ever
listened to speaks the facts never
distorts them
first conservative podcast i subscribe
to love the sunday special uh
trucker bob that sounds great i'm so
glad that you've enjoyed the show
sweet team pasta says you're my go-to
man ben you're my go-to guy for
thoughtful insightful facts related to
all sorts of topics
you make my commute to and from work
productive and i appreciate your
thoroughness on every topic
i'm a centrist that voted both
democratic and republican in the past i
can't stomach the idea of voting
democrat now that they've jumped the
shark keep up the good work well again
these are these are nice reviews i'm
enjoying these ones
oh but here we go yep okay inside the
mind of a demented child
this one's gonna be good with the voice
of a prepubescent boy
and the reasoning skills of rejected
teenager ben shapiro navigates the world
of politics like a true sycophant his
sentences are constructed like a comment
on breitbart
and his pitiful self-soothing assurances
that his master is still mighty
are painful to listen to but do illicit
sympathy get well young man
one day you'll shine like the sun that's
a good review
i can't i kind of enjoy that one r2d2
better
eight that's the name of this account so
it's time to take them seriously
one star hmm how do i say this kindly
this podcast is just
awful it's biased if it wasn't a biased
news source i would listen to this
but this guy is truly annoying in every
way his voice is annoying as hell
biden rules okay so i'm gonna continue
with this review in one second just
a a quick note first if you would listen
to the show if it were on by like what
did you think you were getting
did you think that i was going to be on
like i'm i'm pretty clear about my my
biases
as far as my voice being annoying as
hell fact check true
button rules f trump trump dump is fired
ha ha ha ha stupid conservatives
as a christian i vote democratic it
represents what jesus christ is
except for the abortion rules that's a
small except right there
it's true democrats you know they they
they represent everything jesus christ
believed in
except for christianity and also the
murder of children is that yeah this guy
is not funny and needs to disappear from
the media
well taken r2d2 appreciate it leslie
pearson says spot on ben shapiro is
killing it
grateful for ben's objective approach to
news which is sorely lacking in
mainstream media with data and a
thorough understanding of the law and
history on his side ben calls out both
the pros and cons plus hypocrisy from
all parties involved
i appreciate his often used both and
approach versus either or biased
reporting all too common today
informative smart and funny
oh leslie pearson i'm glad that my mom
is writing reviews now that's pretty
awesome
one star from purifh53
bad just not good
i mean that that's what it says in the
dictionary under bad
vixias one star ben compares trump to
hitler
so true i thought ben supported trump
and the conservative right but he
compares trump to hitler
thanks for shedding light on that ben
you're right the more i thought about
your arguments the more i see the
similarities with trump
and hitler um i have not compared trump
to hitler also
what one star bad boy club 2112
corporate can't respect anyone who loves
hillary this much
sorry uh anyone who loves hillary this
much yeah it's true
that's what i'm known for is my kind
words about hillary clinton jb601
super biased i had heard that ben
shapiro's show was great to listen to
because he was conservative didn't vote
for trump in 2016
would criticize trump frequently i had
high hopes to listen to someone who was
not biased who was objective and
rational i would put country over party
but after listening to a few of his
shows
i am disappointed that he is super
biased towards trump and trump-ism
yes if there's one thing this show is
known for it is definitely
the sycophantic worship of donald trump
that is definitely what we do here
on this show jordan k atkinson one star
please if you like this podcast please
read a history book or turn on some
world news please you need perspective
also msm doesn't mean what you think it
does lol
what does it mean then i don't know what
msm what what
pastoral darryl messina the very best no
one can sell a mattress like ben shapiro
can sell a mattress fact check true
but first a seamless segue will gently
caress your expectations from one of
political humor and truth to an
understanding that deep down this
capitalist company wants to make money
just like the rest of us
and i'll get to why that is right after
we talk about why we all need to get our
hands on a custom mattress just like ben
shapiro has that is
one of the best reviews i've ever seen
that one is very very good
also true helix sleep makes excellent
mattresses
thornton tb says honest five stars ben
will make you say yes that's right or no
no what's wrong with you
as proven by some of these other reviews
but he tells it like he sees it i love
his analogies and temperament
and no one can now debate him he's
quick-witted and sharp as attack he
doesn't drink so sometimes i like to
listen at one half speed
drunk ben is hilarious yes i've gotten
this review many times is that if you
actually speak if you actually take
my podcast speed down to one half then
it sounds as though i'm in a
dorm room arguing with you about the
existence
of your chair uh and drinking heavily at
the same time
biava says ben's bright bold and honest
well i don't agree with all ben's views
he's really great at cutting through all
of the noise to get to the heart of
today's most important issues using
facts and trustworthy sources
he lays bare the overt bias and untruths
regularly pushed by the msm
often simply using their own words to
show how they are constantly pushing
their agenda and relying anyone who
doesn't agree with their version of
events it's my favorite podcast to
listen to each day
thank you for the kind words biaba
that's very nice marvin jg
biased show extremely biased one of my
favorite things about some of the
negative reviews
is when it sounds like a doctor's who's
book for children so i i liked bad
just not good biased joe extremely
biased
redfish bluefish why waste time say lot
word when few words do trick
zj961 if the chipmunks were faux
intellectuals
[Music]
if you're contemplating killing yourself
but haven't been able to follow through
this fake intellectual and
self-important pipsqueak will help you
finally muster the will to end it all
he mistakes talking fast and the odd big
word equate with intelligent thought
well
you mistake incomplete sentences for
complete sentences
so teenager in paradise three clown
faces
wow all the sheep love this clown
it is true you know i walk around town
dressed like a clown and just a bunch of
sheep follow me it's very weird
echo clean what the actual heck doesn't
deal in
reality the gaslighting is extreme also
for the last time antifa is an idea
not a group of people and joe biden did
win the election if you're gonna be a
bigoted idiot at least get your facts
right
antifa is a group of people um
okay acs 999 dork
guy is nuts okay again
that one goes along i love all all the
the reviews where it's like one word
and then a small phrase like it's a
haiku i really like the ones prison mike
he writes one star trash and i never got
caught neither
trash from a little goblin
that sounds like a fantastic children's
book does it not trash from a little
goblin
mama matthews getting paid much ben
sponsors are how he makes money people
you've broken the code my god
they're on to me you listen to his crap
and he gets paid
period wake up people wow i mean
i was hiding the ball there but now the
myth has been exploded
i make money off of the ads i read i
don't just actually do those for fun
who knew speaking of which recon it's
awesome
okay so lots of celebrities love raycon
for example cardi b
you know a fellow platinum award winning
rapper she loves raycons i also love my
raycons raycons offers their wireless
earbuds in range of fun colors and
patterns they are super comfortable they
come with a variety
of fit options the compact carrying case
charges the earbuds four times on a
single charge
unlike some of your other wireless
options raycon earbuds are stylish and
discreet
no dangling wires no stems they are
great for video chats i love them
because they fit my ear
perfectly they start at about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as amazing
as other top audio brands you do know
raycons are great for working from home
working out
listening to music and podcasts for
hours without driving their roommates
significant others children neighbors
crazy
my personal favorite are these yes the
everyday e25 earbuds these are the best
model yet six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass
more compact sound gives you that nice
noise isolating fit it comes in new
fun colors as well look at this
i'm going to open this thing up oh my
god it's unbelievable
check this out
behold click the link in the description
below to get 15
off your order today or head on over to
buy raycon.com
shapiro yt that is byracon.com
shapiro yt you know we need to get back
to the rest of the video
so awesome narwhals
right annoying pretentious troll garbage
okay so again no argument for me
a42b one star ignorant fascist
never listen to the craps so first of
all you should not listen to other
people crapping
it's gross and impolite
of eternal stings never understood that
never understood why people talk to each
other while they're on the toilet now is
not the time for jibber jabber
never listen to the craps also whenever
people call me a fascist i'm like what
the
i'm a libertarian i'm like the opposite
what are you talk but
that guy is right don't listen to the
crabs the shauna 32
right wing bias i find it way too biased
america
deserves better yeah go back and listen
to your objective
news media they're not biased at all i'm
confused by how many reviews
suggest that they were expecting
something unbiased am i unclear on this
clavin makes it look easy five stars
good info ben is no andrew clavin but he
does a good podcast
so first of all glad to see andrew
clavin is listening to the show and
leaving reviews but
actually you should listen to drew's
podcast it is pretty good
for for a man who died 30 years ago
marty 16
nazi apologist if you listen to ben
shapiro i'm begging you to listen to
real news and drink some water
you deserve better so definitely hydrate
also
i am a nazi apologist i always love this
accusation that i
ben shapiro orthodox jew am a nazi
apologist
hmm spot on oh here's another one asad
vladis bad
a sad vlad is bad okay lol
nazi scum compelling compelling stuff
right there
alaskan pure organics racist bigotry
[Applause]
racist ben is a nazi
who spews our hate filled white
supremacist
propaganda yes that's what i'm known for
is the white supremacy
indeed once again nothing says nazi
quite like the yamaka
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
five stars i am obsessed i'm a 27 year
old female my husband has been listening
to ben shapiro for several years now
i never understood his obsession until
this past weekend when my mind felt so
incredibly muddy and confused and
overwhelmed by all of the overwhelming
news about the 2020 election
from the msm needless to say i decided
to give ben shapiro listen and boy am i
glad i did
i am now subscribed to him and planning
on listening to every new episode i felt
so much better after listening to what
he had to say about what is going on in
america right now he's calm collected
logical and extremely objective and an
added bonus he's extremely funny i found
myself continually laughing out loud at
his multiple jokes cannot recommend
listening to him
enough well that's very nice and tell
your husband i say hi as well
okay well if you liked seeing me react
to random comments comment down below on
what i should react to next while you're
at it head on over to the ben shapiro
show on apple podcast and leave us a
five star review
and drown out all the haters by the way
thanks to all of you for making this
show reach the top 10 biggest shows of
the year on apple podcast
and thanks for a great year of making
the ben shapiro show awesome again